informations ponctuelles ce matin
pourrait laisser penser que le numéro un
est allemand a réussi à stopper
l'hémorragie en ouvrant le mur au cours
des dernières 24 heures seulement 605
est allemands se sont réfugiés en rfa or
tous ces derniers jours c'était dix
mille quotidiennement de plus selon la
croix rouge
de plus en plus d'allemands de l'est qui
avaient quitté leur pays rentrent
aujourd'hui chez eux
la croix rouge parle de milliers de
personnes mais revenons au grand concert
de cette nuit un concert pour berlin
auxquels participe et nina hagen la
chanteuse de rock originaire d'allemagne
de l'est reportage de corinne pertuis
soirée choc pour les est-allemand visite
à berlin ouest
une nina hagen provocatrice à souhait de
quoi commencer à combler une frustration
vieille de 30 ans c'est bon je crois que
ça c'est formidable
fille de l'est basé à l'ouest nina hagen
incarné hier soir l'unité de berlin
enfin retrouvé
je désire que les allemands de l'est et
de nouveaux partis de nouvelles
organisations politiques comme ils ont
d'ailleurs toujours désirer et puis des
élections officielles pour le parlement
un vote libre que les partis qui sont
encore son destin puisse être au grand
jour de mon propre parti
le frh et les féminines radical
harmonieuse enfin partie d'importance au
mondial
pourquoi
après trois journées de folie les
berlinois de l'est ont recours le
travail ils ont refait l'affût à la
frontière mais cette fois pour rentrer
chez eux
revenir de l'ouest une sensation qu'ont
ressentie pour la première fois ce
week-end deux millions de berlinois